y
[Música]
el presidente de eeuu joe biden
comenzó su primer viaje por medio
oriente como mandatario
la parada inicial es israel con el que
aspira a fortalecer las relaciones
militares luego viajará a territorios
palestinos y arabia saudita
toque de queda en sri lanka así lo
determinó el primer ministro running
with créeme single luego de que los
manifestantes se tomaron su residencia y
exige exigieran su renuncia el premier
es el mandatario interino luego de que
el presidente contaba ya raya patxi
huyera del país
las protestas en contra de los altos
precios también se viven en américa
latina panamá completa dos semanas de
manifestaciones en argentina desde hoy
comenzó el paro del sector agropecuario
mientras que brasil intenta paliar la
inflexión con subsidios a pocos meses de
las elecciones presidenciales
bienvenidos de nuevo a las noticias de
france 24 los saluda maría clara calle
es un placer acompañarlos
la agenda del día estuvo marcada por el
arribo a israel del presidente de eeuu
joe biden se trata de su primera visita
a la región de medio oriente como
mandatario y su primera parada fue
precisamente israel se espera que el
presidente wyden haga una declaración
conjunta sobre los estratégicos nexos
militares que hay entre los dos países
posteriormente bait en visitar a los
territorios palestinos y viajará a
arabia saudita en este último país se
espera que se ha propuesto un aumento de
la producción de petróleo y analicen el
avance de irán en la región así como su
programa nuclear
yanira gómez corresponsal de france 24
nos da más detalles desde jerusalén
primera jornada corta pero intensa la
que vivió joe biden en su llegada a
israel el presidente estadounidense
arribó en el air force one sobre las
tres y media de la tarde y en el mismo
aeropuerto de tel aviv fue recibido por
el presidente israelí isaac herzog y el
premier israelí en funciones y aísla
pitt estados unidos-israel forman en sus
palabras una amistad y ésta quedó
retratada en los discursos de bienvenida
en gestos de camaradería y en una foto
de familia que también incluyó al ex
primer ministro y actual líder opositor
benjamín netanyahu las alocuciones
aunque también breves sirvieron para
marcar algunos de los temas de esta
primera gira de bailén por medio oriente
como presidente mientras la [__] habló
de una coalición global contra irán
vaivén que visita a israel por décima
vez en su carrera política reiteró el
compromiso de eeuu con la seguridad de
israel y defendió en una solución de dos
estados para el conflicto
palestino-israelí admitiendo luego que
no la ve posible a corto plazo esa
defensa israelí se plasmó desde el mismo
aeropuerto con una exhibición
armamentística que tuvo como principal
atracción el prototipo de un láser
antimisiles
2 iron bean que como la cúpula de hierro
podría beneficiarse de financiación
estadounidense luego badén se trasladó a
jerusalén oeste y allí rindió tributo a
las víctimas del holocausto en el museo
yad vashem donde además de algo con dos
sobrevivientes judías e instó a combatir
el veneno del antisemitismo fuera de lo
simbólico incluso antes de su aterrizaje
en by denny lápiz firmaron un pacto de
cooperación para el desarrollo de
tecnologías centrado en la inteligencia
artificial un acuerdo antesala de los
anuncios oficiales que se esperan este
jueves después de que bailen y lápiz
tengan su primer cara a cara a solas
como mandatarios un foro virtual con los
líderes de emiratos árabes unidos e
india y encuentros con here shock y
netanyahu completan la agenda política
de bailén antes de desplazarse el
viernes a territorios palestinos y
arabia saudita
en otras noticias en ser y la ncaa
continúa la crisis política ahora los
ciudadanos también exigen la renuncia
del primer ministro running we crema
single él asumió como presidente
interino luego de que el mandatario
gotabaya rajapaksa huyera del país
actualmente está en las islas maldivas y
busca exilio en otra nación por su parte
del premier declaró estado de emergencia
este miércoles y toque de queda para
comenzar a mitigar la crisis sin embargo
el descontento social aumenta y en las
calles exigen un nuevo gobierno
la salida de raya pasa no termina con la
crisis los manifestantes volcados en las
calles exigen ahora la renuncia del
primer ministro y créame singer quien es
el presidente interino un aliado del
depuesto presidente que no yo las
maldivas
[Aplausos]
el rey mire usted
ramil bicrim en zinc nos ha fallado como
primer ministro nosotros toda la gente
no lo quiere como presidente
el primer ministro quien anunció que
renunciaría cuando haya un nuevo
gobierno respondió con fuerza a los
manifestantes y trató de disolver las
protestas con más represión ceniza de
atún pedí debido a la situación de hoy
las fuerzas de seguridad me aconsejaron
declarar el estado de emergencia e
imponer el toque de queda debemos
derrotar esta amenaza fascista dándole
la oposición que se autoproclama como el
cambio que el país necesita está en
contra de las medidas del gobierno
jean-marc de nigrán y no sólo condenó
con vehemencia estos ataques a personas
desarmadas que están protestando sino
que me comprometo a derrotar esto con el
poder del pueblo y las protestas en esta
isla de asia del sur llevan meses y
alcanzaron su punto más fuerte el fin de
semana cuando miles de personas tomaron
las residencias de los líderes políticos
de la ncaa atraviesa una de sus peores
crisis con una inflación galopante
escasez de alimentos y la corrupción en
el centro de las denuncias los
legisladores acordaron elegir un nuevo
presidente la próxima semana pero el
martes tuvieron dificultades para
decidir la composición de un nuevo
gobierno y tal como ocurre en seri lanka
en américa latina' también hay protestas
por el incremento del costo de vida
panamá vive su segunda semana de
manifestaciones en contra del alza de
los precios del combustible y de los
alimentos el gobierno de laurentino
cortizo ya aplicó unas medidas para
sobrellevar la crisis sin embargo ahora
cada sector tiene más exigencias
particulares nuestro corresponsal oscar
sulbarán nos amplía
el cacique de la comarca kuna ha
decidido salir a las calles en la ciudad
de panamá en representación de los
pueblos indígenas la razón de su
protesta se debe a el alto costo del
combustible y los alimentos y a la
defensa de su territorio estamos ahí
siguiendo al gobierno la demarcación
crítica a las comarcas que le hace falta
de los hermanos originarios del país
también estamos pidiendo el desalojo de
todos los colonos instalados en nuestras
comarcas la invasión es que te vea
diariamente con nuestros territorios
pero no solo los indígenas están
inconformes desde el sector público de
la salud reclaman un sistema apto para
atender a los panameños
[Música]
para nada
todavía lo
teniendo mayor corte
las protestas iniciadas por los
educadores hace más de una semana por el
alto costo de la vida han tenido como
respuesta por parte del ejecutivo el
congelamiento del precio del combustible
el control de precios para una serie de
productos y medidas de austeridad pero
para los manifestantes aún sigue siendo
insuficiente es necesario y urgente
darle a nuestros estudiantes lo que se
merecen por la y constitución ningún
gobierno quiere cumplir eso ha nacido
una esperanza y una bandera de más de 25
años y hasta el momento señor parecían
benito cortizo el momento ahora el
gobierno panameño por ahora está en una
situación difícil maniobrando con las
peticiones y reclamos de los distintos
sectores pero además sin dinero porque
la deuda pública se ha incrementado en
al menos 50 por ciento y supera los 40
mil millones de dólares
y en argentina las principales
asociaciones de trabajadores
agropecuarios iniciaron una protesta
contra el gobierno paralizando sus
actividades por 24 horas la denominada
jornada federal de demanda se llevó a
cabo con asambleas en distintos puntos
del país expresan al ejecutivo de
alberto fernández su rechazo a la
presión fiscal sobre el sector que se ve
reflejada en una menor rentabilidad
además protestan por la escasez de dice
el gobierno tiene una visión equivocada
de lo que es el campo evidentemente en
sus diagnósticos equivocados
nos lleva a una excesiva presión
impositiva a un doble mercado cambiario
que afecta a la rentabilidad ya
un ajuste lógico los valores del dólar
que permitan tener una exportación
razonable y que eso pues tener un marco
de rentabilidad que pueda mostrar al
productor de que es viable para poder
seguirse el alza del precio del
combustible fue la razón que justificó
el parlamento de brasil para probar la
medida que pidió el presidente de jair
bolsonaro hoy los legisladores
declararon estado de emergencia hasta
final de año y aprobaron que el gobierno
reparta más de 7.600 millones de dólares
en subsidios sin embargo la medida fue
duramente criticada pues la oposición
afirma que es una estrategia electoral
de bolsonaro ya que los brasileños irán
a comicios presidenciales el próximo 2
de octubre y bolsonaro aspira a la
reelección
los suministros también son un tema de
discusión en la guerra en ucrania hoy
representantes ucranianos y rusos se
reunieron en estambul para intentar
retomar las exportaciones de granos a
través del mar negro recordemos que la
mayoría de los puertos están controlados
por los militares de moscú turquía y
naciones unidas- intentan mediar en los
diálogos y según el ministro de defensa
turco podrían alcanzar un pacto la
próxima semana no se descarta la opción
de corredores marítimos
este avión aterrizó en el aeropuerto de
estambul a bordo viaja una delegación de
expertos rusos ucranianos turcos y los
representantes de la onu su objetivo
tratar de llegar a un acuerdo para
asegurar la exportación de cereales
desde ucrania tras varios intentos la
confianza es baja especialmente para
kiev aunque el ministro de exteriores
ucraniano espera garantías de seguridad
nos alegraremos de que los barcos
lleguen a nuestros puertos y se marchen
con seguridad para todos tanto para los
transportistas como para los
propietarios de los cereales y también
para nuestros puertos pero para que eso
ocurra tenemos que resolver el problema
de la falta de confianza en rusia
ninguno de nosotros ninguno de los
participantes en estas discusiones
confía en rusia
por el momento rusia sigue manteniendo
un bloqueo en el mar negro que va desde
la costa rusa hasta la frontera rumana e
impide la salida de barcos ucranianos
para permitir el paso de los barcos
moscú exige inspecciones y el desminado
de las aguas quien se ha negado hasta
ahora a este último punto en el centro
de los debates está la creación de
corredores marítimos el tiempo para
llegar a un acuerdo sobre las
exportaciones de granos se está acabando
el precio de los alimentos aumenta lo
que hace temer una hambruna
especialmente en áfrica
ucrania es el quinto exportador mundial
de trigo y el cuarto mayor exportador de
maíz el país también representa el 50
por ciento del comercio mundial de
semillas y aceite de girasol por el
momento 20 mil millones de toneladas de
grano ucraniano siguen bloqueadas en los
puertos de la región de odessa turquía
dice que tiene 20 barcos en el mar negro
listos para embarcar las pero todavía no
se ha llegado a un acuerdo
en más actualidad de la guerra las
tropas rusas llevando a cabo una serie
de bombardeos en el sur de ucrania
provocando la muerte de al menos cinco
personas en la ciudad de mykolaiv
entretanto en la ciudad de sap orilla
dos misiles rusos impactaron una fábrica
local en donde 14 personas resultaron
heridas
estas acciones por parte de las tropas
rusas ratifican la intención de moscú de
agilizar su avance y conquistar el sur
ucraniano además corea del norte
reconoció la independencia de los
autoproclamados repúblicas populares de
donges y lugares que hasta ahora
solamente reconocidas por rusia y siria
en respuesta los ucranianos rompieron
relaciones diplomáticas con los
norcoreanos
y ahora hablamos del reino unido porque
el partido conservador comenzó a votar
para elegir a su nuevo líder la lista se
ha ido reduciendo y ahora hay seis
candidatos entre los que se encuentran
el ex secretario de economía luis y
sunat y la ex secretaria de defensa
penny more down el foco de la batalla se
centra en ambos candidatos quienes hasta
ahora se llevan la mayor cantidad de
votaciones
la carrera para liderar el reino unido y
hasta en marcha aunque para algunos ya
ha terminado
existe una 88 350 tu gente a 37 zahawi
25 decisión o huawei twenty five
por lo tanto según las reglas que
acordamos para esta votación dos
candidatos serán eliminados jeremy hunt
y eddie saharaui web y el replay ser los
intentos del ex secretario de salud
germán hunt así como de eddie saharaui
para convertirse en el nuevo primer
ministro del país terminaron pronto
mientras que richie son aquí y venimos
donde van a la delantera listos gaming
band the knack champ tugendhat y estela
braverman completan la lista de los seis
candidatos restantes ya que el jueves se
celebrará una segunda ronda de
votaciones en los próximos días los que
tengan menos votos serán descartados
antes del gran enfrentamiento en el que
los 160.000 miembros del partido
conservador decidirán quién en los
últimos candidatos quieren que dirija el
país
al igual que cualquiera de ellos
limpiaría el suelo con el capitán raúl y
snoods ex señor presidente y después de
unas semanas eso es exactamente lo que
harán se unirán en torno al ganador y
harán precisamente eso
en el presidente me iré pronto con la
cabeza en alto estas son las palabras de
boris johnson dirigidas al líder de la
oposición mientras pasa sus últimas
semanas en el cargo antes de su salida
prevista para el mes de septiembre
quieres tomar el líder laborista
respondió diciendo que johnson era
totalmente iluso y que echaría de menos
sus tonterías semanales durante el turno
de preguntas al primer ministro
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]